die grundstücke in kratzeburg ortsteil
dambeck in mecklenburg vorpommern sind
seit ende des vergangenen jahrhunderts
fein säuberlich an die kanalisation
angeschlossen ihren abwasseranschluss
haben die menschen damals teuer bezahlt
aber jetzt nach 20 jahren werden viele
noch mal zur kasse gebeten manche einer
sollen mehr als 10.000 euro nachzahlen
im mecklenburgischen seen land geht die
existenzangst um abzocke ich da nur
sagen
also alles weg jetzt ich kann dich für
eine sache die 20 jahre her ist und
bezahlt worden ist ich hab ja schon mal
bezahlt dann plötzlich sagen so jetzt
brauche ich noch mal für die selber noch
mal geld hat geht auch gar nicht zu
machen wir einen was sie wollen und
immer fühlt sich verarscht vom staat mit
bis zum gehtnichtmehr
ende der 90er jahre wurden in dambeck
rohre verlegt und die kunst ganz
abwassernetz angeschlossen familie frank
zahlte damals für ihren anschluss mehr
als 11.000 d-mark einmalig wie es hieß
aber jahre später erklärte das
oberverwaltungsgericht greifswald die
satzung des wasserzweckverbandes
strelitz für nichtig die folge bis ende
2018 muster der kommunale verband 6.500
neue schmutzwasser bescheide erlassen
manche bekommen etwas zurück familie
frank dagegen muss noch mal über 8000
euro zahlen so wie ihnen geht es vielen
anderen auch unterm strich macht der
verband ein plus von rund zwei millionen
euro
wenn man so die bescheide sieht oder
gehört hat wie viel jeder bezahlen muss
ja da bleibt ändern schon die spucke weg
sag ich meinte im oktober mit dem
bescheid gekriegt selber innerhalb von
vier wochen und dann war weihnachten und
so viel geld hat man nicht auf bekannte
vor der kamera möchte sich niemand vom
wasserzweckverband strehle zu äußern
schriftlich heißt es man habe keinerlei
messen bei der nacherhebungspflicht von
beiträgen das kommunale abgabengesetz
mecklenburg vorpommerns normiert die
beitragspflicht es gab nur hinsichtlich
der höhe des beitrages einer messen den
bürgerinnen und bürgern hilft das nicht
sie halten das ganze für ausgemachten
unsinn ich kann es nicht verstehen dass
wenn man einmal eine sache abgegolten
hat dass man da noch wieder
nachforderung auf den tisch bekommt eine
große sauerei was sie mache ihr bild
viele betroffene haben sich jetzt eine
sammelklage angeschlossen am ende muss
wohl wieder ein gericht entscheiden ob
die menschen in dambeck für ihren
anschluss ans abwassernetz wirklich
doppelt zahlen müssen